[Applause]
what happens when a man stands up says
enough was enough
[Music]
today we are joined by the co-founder of
the african-american Film Critics
Association Sean Edwards to highlight a
few films from a much larger list he
published that highlight black cinema
Sean how are you man you know I'm
holding up considering the circumstances
is a really interesting time man a lot
of historical things are happening so uh
I'm kind of playing part observer and
part participant so you know splitting
the time between the two I hear you man
I'm super glad you're here I would love
to hear some of your recommendations no
I appreciate it man I mean this is a
great time to explore cinema through the
lens of the black experience and hey if
you're going to do that I recommend
starting first with do the right thing
it was released in 1989 and I really
might choose do the right thing as the
starting point is because first and
foremost it's just a really great movie
with cinema the movie has to be good but
this movie is great it's directed by
Spike Lee and this movie does so many
things it's so weird it's it's actually
very complex but it's actually easily
digestible and it does the one thing I
like movies to do when you're done
watching it actually creates a reason to
have a conversation you know and discuss
what you just saw I love this film does
that I also love the fact that this film
still holds up now a lot of people may
think it's pretty sad that we're still
dealing with the same issues 31 years
later but it's also a testament to Spike
Lee that as a genius filmmaker he was
completely in touch with what is going
on
even back then and now the reason this
movie works is because you get to know
the characters in the neighborhood so it
provides context which is really
important in the way things unfold so
you know who you're dealing with and
Spike Lee does a tremendous job of
really developing and exploring the
different characters that live
throughout the neighborhood
now things sort of come to a tragic
conclusion because there's this
gathering spot there's a pizzeria and
some cultural things happen inside the
pizzeria they've kind of sparked some
unrest in the neighborhood and Spike Lee
plays the main character his name is
Mookie he's actually a delivery guy for
the pizzeria and he's sort of a person
who ignites to riot so hence the title
do the right thing it's one of the
better setups ever and after you see it
you'll come back to me and say okay I
get what you were saying but no this
movie explores race it explores the
effects of gentrification explorers
police brutality it explores police
profiling this movie explores a lot of
different issues that you know African
Americans were dealing with in 1989's
and African Americans are dealing with
in 2020 in all the years in between you
know he sparks controversy at the same
time he's educated and that's what makes
do the right thing the best starting
point if you're going to explore the
black experience through the lens of
cinema okay let's talk about a movie
that's a little more current it's called
the hate you give in the U is just the
letter U so if you're looking it up as -
hey the letter U you give 2018 film
directed by George Tillman Jr the genius
of this movie is it's actually based
upon a why a novel which stands for
young adult this is a very sophisticated
film to be based on Hawaii now because
it deals with some very very heavy
issues but the main characters played by
Amandla Stenberg and she's fantastic in
this movie actually thought they just
came out she should have been nominated
for Best Actress she really is that good
in the movie but the center point of the
movie is she witnesses the murder of her
best friend at the hands of the police
they mistakenly he reaches for a
hairbrush they mistakenly think it's a
gun and they take its life this happens
right yeah exactly this happens right in
front of her so then the film explores
the impact of that on her young life and
she's already been off issues that a lot
of African Americans deal with in the
film whereas she sort of has like this
dump well why she attends a private prep
school where she has to operate a
certain way
and she has to come back to her urban
environment in which she has to deal
with life in a certain way and then her
father was recently just released from
prison but he was sparsely accused so
now he's out dealing with those issues
and she has a funcle' was played by
common who's an actual police officer so
as you can see she's navigating a lot of
different worlds but the thing that
really makes this movie so special is it
shows how young people are usually at
the forefront of any change or any new
movement and she decides to lead you
know a protest and she's at the front of
that and it's just a does a great job of
exploring her situation and the way she
deals with everything that she has to go
through from the murder of her friend
right in front of her eyes to dealing
with how to see who galvanized the
community and demand social justice very
powerful very emotional I yeah if you're
gonna choose movies off these lists I
don't think you can watch them back to
back to back because you're going to
need some time to breathe after watching
each one but there really are great
movies that explore a lot of the things
that are happening right now and as they
hate to get released in 2018 Wow okay
yeah that's a great angle yeah because
it deals with the perspective of a
teenager and I love that aspect of the
film now if you really want to
understand sort of like the roots of the
civil right movement then I recommend
selma directed by Ava Duvernay
was released in 2014 and at the center
of this movie is Martin Luther King jr.
but it deals with the civil rights
movement and their attempts to put on a
march from the city of Selma Alabama to
the Capitol Alabama which is Montgomery
Alabama this is a great historical
documentation it also shows a little bit
of how you know the civil rights
movement you sort of like its political
muscle and angles to make their cars
more effective because their scenes with
Martin Luther King and then press
lyndon b johnson in the white house and
there are other civil rights movements
that are focused on a you kinda see how
they created their strategy of protests
so that they can get the demands that
they wanted but at the end of this movie
is probably the most powerful piece of
cinema you could ever watch because it
deals with the protesters and marchers
attempting to cross this bridge on their
pathway from Selma to Montgomery Alabama
and they're attacked by two local police
the National Guard the state troopers
and some of those scenes are extremely
violent and extremely heartbreaking and
extremely hard to watch but they
actually happen so it's just something
you have to sort of deal with because
it's an actual part of American history
that took place back in the day and this
film does a great job of capturing that
and painting the picture and showing you
what these peaceful demonstrators went
through in the name of civil rights the
speeches that are featured in the movie
that dr. Martin Luther King delivers
aren't the actual speeches but they're
still stirring and powerful and this
demonstrates a great job of writing a
table duvan they did when writings
complan great now I know these movies
that I've talked about are all sort of
light feature films so I wanted to put
at least one documentary on the list
because documentaries are nonfiction
pieces of work so I selected I am NOT
your negro which was released in 2016
one of the best documentaries ever made
this documentary is mind blowing Lee
powerful because it features James
Baldwin and a lot of is James Baldwin
his ideology his philosophy his speeches
on how african-americans have been
treated you know in the United States
since you know 1619 all the way through
the late 60s and man when you hear these
words and when you hear the way he
examines the way that African Americans
have been treated in this country and
sort of like his plan of action for
social justice I mean there's nothing
more moving and mercenary than watching
these actual speeches that you know many
of which were televised you know back in
the you know 1960s early 70s that really
get you fired up that's just a great
documentation
of sort of like the plight of the
african-american man and woman
throughout the years it's just a really
moving and strong documentary it's
called I am NOT your negro if you're in
the nonfiction if you're into
documentaries I highly recommend that
bill I'm definitely gonna check
I'm never gonna check all these out I'm
sure in this way though okay a lot of
these movies are heavy and sometimes you
want to learn about what's going on
without ba like yeah just something to
this like this vacuum uh oh my god I
can't believe you know so I chose for
the final film black and blue which was
released in 2019 and black and blue is a
fantastic demonstration of how just a
pure action movie can actually deal with
heavy-handed issues without beating you
over the head or being even you know
obvious at all and it deals with like a
black police officer played by Naomi
Harris who's like terrific in the movie
I think it's early first leading role
and she like kills it so she's an
officer on the police force she
witnesses some officers doing some I
know some some things they shouldn't be
doing he gets captured on her body cam
and then there's like this investigation
in this chase that takes place because
she's trying to do the right thing and
they're trying to stop her from doing
the right thing but it's just a good
example how cinema even when it's not
trying to be quote-unquote pretentious
or heavy-handed can still deliver a very
powerful message while you're being
entertained at the same time is directed
by Dion Taylor has some of the most
incredible action sequences I've seen in
a long time and as I said being know my
Harris who plays like the lead officer
is fantastic in the movie it's actually
the first time an African American
woman's played a police officer in a
leading role and I like the fact that
not all the police officers are white
some of them are black as well it's just
you know if you do wrong you do wrong
if you do right you do right so it
doesn't really draw anything you know
according to racial wives it's like hey
these are the police some of them are
some of them are good some of them are
bad and this is how their activities
affect the community I mean it's what
you a quote unquote call a popcorn movie
but it has a very strong business to
begin you don't really realize it into
the any like oh okay I have a lot of fun
watching this but now I get it
and then there's a great job of doing
that awesome dude what a succinct list I
appreciate you like giving the like kind
of like what the entity the point of
each of them is joining me and like I
appreciate different perspective that
they hate to give has a like a fantastic
perspective from a teenager
Selma's the historical approach you got
it through a documentary on there which
is what I am NOT your Negro represents
and then you need just like a regular
I'm trying to have fun while I'm
watching something in oops oh by the way
there's a message there movie which is
black and blue which came I lasted learn
but you still sometimes we don't watch
movies to have some fun so you know yeah
absolutely I totally get that
well the full list of 110 films that
Sean and his peers created if you want
to check that out it's up on
fandango.com or put a link in the
description I challenge all of you to
watch all five of these at the very
least I'm gonna do the same if you do
leave a comment below and let me know
that you you did the challenge as well
Sean thank you so much for joining us
today I appreciate you man I love the
show love the energy man thanks for
having me on man it's always fun to talk
to movies man I can do it yeah all day
all night all year long so I really
appreciate it absolutely man anytime
[Music]